the furrier cuts out the suede leather
parts a hydraulic press known as a
clicker drives the dyes through the
leather to punch out the pieces the
largest one will be used for the bottom
and sides of the moccasins it's called
the foot
the other parts are a sole to reinforce
the bottom and the vamp which is the
upper part of the slipper
[Music]
next the fire cuts out pieces of thick
polyester fleece which will be used to
create plush liners he arranges the
moccasin components in the correct
sequence for sewing this is called a
layup and it helps the sewing process go
faster
[Music]
she sews beaded designs into this
moccasins upper
[Music]
these geometric designs are a nod to the
past but their purpose is purely
ornamental not spiritual after lining
the beaded vamp with fleece the worker
stitches a leather strip around the
edges creating a border known as a welt
the Walt gives the vamp a more
attractive finish - so the vamp - the
rest of the moccasin she uses a special
sewing machine it pleats the top of the
foot to fit the vamp as it stitches
[Music]
the moccasins are now structurally
complete and they're ready for the fur
trim
the worker stitches the rabbit fur
strips together to create one long strip
that will fit to the moccasin the length
of the strip will vary depending on the
size of the moccasin she makes an
initial chain stitch and then doubles
back to lock the stitch down in order to
prevent it from unraveling
she aligns the fur trim with the collar
of the moccasin and sews it to it
[Music]
after stitching the worker leaves the
fur tucked down into the moccasin
this makes it easier to apply glue
around the top of the moccasin so that
when the fur is folded up and over it it
stays in place with that this modern-day
version of traditional indigenous
Footwear is ready for its first steps
[Music]